foreign
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
where everything is all fun and games
until it isn't so it's been a bit of a
hot minute since we last talked about
spoopy scary animatronics on this
channel over a year in fact it's a long
time especially when you consider that
some other channels out there are able
to get like a video a week out of that
sort of stuff I mean who do you think we
are that said there is a series that
I've been wanting to talk about that
scratches the same animatronic itch
Harmony and horror created by the
incredibly talented animator baddington
right here on youtube.com now if you've
watched any analog horror before or you
follow our theories covering them you
know the drill it's the 80s everything
is on low quality VHS camera footage and
things that are normally fun in this
case toys are getting corrupted turning
scary attacking nearby security guards
man this really is like FNAF isn't it I
just can't escape it another thing
Harmony and horror borrows from its FNAF
father is a complicated timeline in
classic analog horror fashion the
uploads here aren't happening in
chronological order which means that
putting together a timeline of events
gets challenging we see that same event
from multiple different perspectives
those uploads are happening more than a
year apart characters are pulling double
duty there is a lot of mystery here
what's more it appears that the story of
Harmony and horror is being told to us
through literal tapes in Universe with
most of the uploads starting as a VHS
tape that gets put into a VCR meaning
that there is a meta layer on top of all
of this so with my FNAF timeline finally
done and written I wanted to sit down
and put together another animatronic
Story one that's much scarier and isn't
afraid to go darker that said before we
dive in I do want to say that this
theory is only going to be talking about
season one yeah season two is already
underway but considering how much there
is to cover in season one we wouldn't be
doing the series Justice if we tried
cramming it all together so do me a
favor try not to spoil anything from
season 2 down in the comments we'll be
saving that one for another video
without any further Ado dim the lights
and hug your Stitch buddy close you're
gonna need him it's time to tell the
tragic tale of a family that's been
broken apart by greed and ultimately
held together reluctantly by Satan
himself our story follows the gray
Winder fan family Martin his wife Gloria
and their three children Thomas Macy and
their infant girl Ava Martin and his
brother Arthur co-found a toy
manufacturing company called M A Harmony
toys along with an entertainment
production company called M A Harmony
play Productions the m a here obviously
standing for the brothers Martin and
Arthur now sadly things don't seem to be
going too well for the both of them in
the video are you happy we see the
screen briefly glitched to reveal a
newspaper clipping reviewing one of
their toys Henry the puppet doll and the
criticism isn't kind saying that the toy
feels more dead than alive this
infuriates the prideful and jealous
Martin starting an obsession to make the
most lifelike toys imaginable by
incorporating parts of real-life
creatures
said would be a bad idea is the way to
fix it Arthur begs him to stop but
Martin refuses partly out of obsession
partly out of Pride but mostly because
Arthur is having an affair with Martin's
wife Gloria
with his life crumbling around him
Martin becomes angry and violent
especially towards his son Thomas
it gets bad enough that the police
eventually have to intervene as we see
in the video rebirth
know why you're here today doesn't have
anything to do with me and Mommy but
yourself no by 1982 Martin's become a
full-on murderer we see this in the
videos are you happy and what went wrong
two Archives of the local children show
that Martin produces through Harmony
play Productions and what they depict is
uh it is truly disturbing in the video's
two children and their dog Bonzo visit a
traveling toy maker in the hopes that
he'll make him the perfect toy the toy
maker agrees but is sad because he can't
make the toys more lifelike my toys
my toys can walk but they can't dance my
toys can eat but they can
can't make the toys more lifelike huh
it's almost like art imitates life
regardless the kids offer to help the
toy maker out so he sends them out on a
series of fetch quests this includes
bringing back a needle and thread paint
and fabric and perhaps most strangely
their dog Bonzo what do you need him for
the toy needs to be happy
this then becomes his first monstrous
creation a giant living version of
Stitch buddy with the spirit of the dog
inside of it
large dangerous and obedient Martin
loves his creation so he continues the
final ingredient he needs for their
perfect toy is their voice asking the
kids to repeat after him but before we
hear what he's saying the tape is
interrupted by a federal warning telling
viewers that if any of the original
audio or video from the section of the
broadcast remains they must close their
eyes cover their ears and turn their
head around 180 degrees Public Access
television ain't great but can't be that
bad right towards the end of the tape
we're shown pictures of several kids who
died in 1982. the same year as this
particular broadcast under each picture
is the child's cause of death one that
came from a seizure while watching his
favorite show the other whose head was
facing backwards both of these are
heavily implying that whatever happened
to these kids was caused by the cut part
of the broadcast the whole event would
eventually come to be known as the
harmony broadcast incident but evil
tapes that's only the beginning of
Martin's descent into depravity around
the same time Amy Wilson Martin's intern
at M A Harmony toys goes missing here's
the thing this isn't the first time we
hear of this character either one of
those pictures of people who died in 82
was labeled Amy Wilson but she wasn't
the victim of some TV broadcast gone
wrong she was murdered by Martin her
picture says she stopped screaming when
her spine came out whew that's just a
that is just a special layer of dark and
it would seemed like the harmony
broadcast incident was Martin's
confession to this particular crime you
see when the boys from the cartoon go to
collect the needle and thread they get
it out of a body bag with a human corpse
inside of it just look at that face it
is floppy and structureless almost like
it's skull and spine were removed just
like Amy Wilson hold on going from
cuckolded husband and jealous toy maker
to serial murderer I mean that is a
massive leap of escalation why why did
these kids die why did Martin kill Amy
Wilson why is he resorting to releasing
a creepy evil video broadcast if he's
just obsessed with creating life-like
toys the answer my friends is Satan the
devil literally made him do it right at
the beginning of the video are you happy
we get this line I'm true you
interrupted my tree I was dreaming about
to man dressed in red with ice cream
cones that's ridiculous Marcus oh a man
dressed in red with ice cream cones on
his head ice cream cones or horns later
in what went wrong we actually see the
silhouette of this very man it's a
figure that's so intimidating it scares
the toy maker I just need more time you
just need to give me more time you just
need to give me more time no no no no no
not only that but we see evidence of
demonic rituals happening outside of
that particular video as well in she
can't sleep we see another toy the
singing Sophia doll hidden inside of a
closet surrounded by candles and a
crucifix on the wall almost looks like
some sort of rituals happening we see
more of those candles lined up in the
toy maker shop during the harmony
broadcast incident and in the video good
boy we get confirmation as to what's
happening Martin is killing things and
then performing Satanic rituals to bind
souls to the various toys around the toy
shop his first successful victim is the
dog Bonzo who gets fused into the giant
animalistic Stitch Buddy toy
the part that was clipped from the
harmony broadcast incident yep it had to
have been some sort of demonic
incantation that certain viewers at home
felt the need to repeat he clearly made
a deal with the devil to make his toys
more lifelike and all of it for
Perfection and control especially
control he really likes that feeling and
it's something that we're gonna watch
him assert on his family over and over
again across the next four videos
frustrated at the lack of control that
he has over his family and his wife
Martin breaks as he puts his daughter
Macy to sleep Martin seems distracted
and sad refusing to sing her a lullaby
but he promises to quote make her a doll
that can sing a promise that he will
literally make true later that night he
reminds Macy that he and Mommy have a
business meeting in the morning and that
she might not be seeing her mother for a
while but clearly there is no business
meeting here instead Martin confronts
Gloria about her infidelity and in the
video she can't sleep we hear the
aftermath of that conversation Gloria
frantically enters Macy's room waking
her before the Para attacked by Stitch
buddy after a glitch we hear Gloria
hiding Macy before Martin ultimately
finds and kills Gloria Martin though far
from deterred continues to hunt he moves
on to Macy Thomas and Ava binding each
to a different toy in the m a roster
now wherever you are okay we got a
special surprise for you Thomas becomes
Henry the puppet Macy becomes Sophia the
singing marionette and Ava the baby
becomes well this thing
now with control over his family Martin
seems happy again with a pep in his step
he introduces a new mascot named the ice
cream man to his brother Arthur
believing that this character is gonna
be a hit for the company but Arthur is
done unaware of the previous night's
Rampage Arthur reveals that he's talked
to Gloria and that she and the kids are
leaving with him at least until Martin
gets his act together that's when Martin
reveals that he's already fixed their
quote-unquote little problem
interestingly this is exactly what the
toy maker says during the harmony
broadcast incident at this point Martin
has basically become the character I am
not going to let anyone let me down
including you using his demonic rituals
Martin then fuses his brother into the
ice cream man's suit but even though
he's gone parts of Arthur's Soul still
shine through in a scene split across
two separate videos released a year
apart we see that Arthur in the form of
the ice cream man forces Martin to pay
for his crimes
legitimately it's a cool creative choice
but as you might suspect this is far
from the end of Martin he suffers the
exact same fate as his family his body
disappearing and his soul becoming
trapped inside yet another animatronic
toy puppet thing everything's been used
I suppose you could say he always comes
back this time though we're dealing with
the creepy clown known as the jester at
this point the outside world considers
the gray winders to have vanished we see
a news report in the video Local 13
detailing a police raid on the gray
Winder household while they find no
signs of Martin or his family they do
discover the bodies of eight other
victims with their limbs cut off and
their skin empty presumably the people
that he killed make his first wave of
monstrosities with the gray Winder is
now gone some other corporate entity
swoops in and buys the business taking
over the m a Harmony toy store and
continuing to sell the evil dolls so is
that the end obviously not we find out
exactly where the family is these days
thanks to the title of the next video
which is uh this if you're an ARG
veteran you'll recognize this as an
encrypted sentence in a simple Caesar
Cipher if you shift each of the letters
in the title back by one it reads they
are inside the building their souls are
still trapped there inside the toys
begging for release bashing their heads
against the wall in an attempt to escape
and bit by bit they're losing themselves
to whatever demonic curse that Martin
cast on them in I want a toy we see the
Henry puppet doll sing before breaking
down as a literal demon crawls out of
his head and don't cry if you refuse to
sing with Sophia her face opens up and a
demonic tentacle comes out to attack the
viewer and in goodbye my loved ones
Arthur's Spirit straight up tells us
that he doesn't have much time left
but most interestingly he asks the
viewer to stop him
stop him from what exactly from
attacking and hurting innocent people
several of the videos feature the toys
at the m a Harmony toy store coming to
life attacking the security guards
crawling through the vents to get to
them and one shot here features a
grotesque pink monster that right there
that is Arthur that is what he's been
cursed to become and through it all
Martin's soul is still within the jester
haunting the store right alongside the
rest of them trapped in a nightmare of
his own creation Now we could certainly
leave things there and we'd already have
ourselves a tragic compelling story a
man so obsessed with creating Perfection
that he ends up being the downfall of
his own family but we're not done yet
you'll notice that one member of the
family avoided being stuffed into an
animatronic suit as it were Martin's
wife Gloria for whatever reason she
isn't transformed into a toy and she
isn't cursed in the same way as the rest
of her family so where then is she she
can't have been the only one to have
escaped right right she's here too
throughout all of the videos if you pay
attention you'll notice a ghost
appearing in the background to several
shots she appears in are you happy as a
ghost lingering in the background in
through broken windows she's behind the
image of her son in wake up Bonzo she's
emerging from the shadows in henry.mp4
she's staring into the toy shot and most
importantly in goodbye Arthur she's
reaching a handout and begging the
viewer to come with me but why why has
she invaded these tapes this Archive of
all of Martin's sins why is she breaking
the fourth wall to tell us to come with
her why is she talking to us well it's
because we are Martin we are the jester
we are literally the bad guy of this
story re-watching these tapes over and
over and over obsessing over the details
of her life trapped inside of this
nightmare at the top of the theory I
mentioned how most of the uploads in the
series begin with a VHS tape being
inserted into a VCR what I didn't
mention is that if you look closely you
can see the reflection of the character
watching the tapes inside the television
screen out right there as a great detail
and whose reflection is staring back at
us every time Martin the jester he's
watching the tapes and Gloria is using
the tapes to try and get through to him
to us in the season 1 finale come back
to me Gloria's Twisted face calms the
wide-eyed scream becoming a solemn
sadness it's here that she reveals that
she was the one playing these tapes for
us showing us the story begging Martin
to see what he's done how he's hurt the
family how they were all proud of him
before his deal with the devil how he
can still come back to them and make
things right and for a minute it seems
like there might be hope the beginning
of this video reveals that the field
from rest assure where all his fears and
regrets from his life can't hurt him
that was actually where he had his first
date with Gloria where they started
their relationship which led to their
family that's a place where he doesn't
have to be the jester he doesn't have to
be the toy maker or whatever his deal
with the devil turned him into but
Martin can't come back at least he
doesn't want to whether it's because of
his Rage or his regret or his corruption
Martin is too far gone he breaks the
television and banishes glorious Spirit
as the screen shatters so there you have
it that's Harmony and Horror season one
or at least the best I could do at
putting together this fragmented
narrative into the heartbreaking story
of a man's destructive need for
perfection and control as I mentioned
before baddington has already started
season two so if you want to get there
before I do my next Theory go check it
out link is down in the description
below and hey if there are other little
known online series that you want me to
check out leave them down in the
comments I'm accepting all
recommendations bonus points if there
are no animatronics or possessed spirits
but hey if you want to check out some
more killer content why don't you go
check out our brand new style Theory
Channel all about Fashion Beauty and
hygiene that sounds a bit strange yeah I
get it seems like a weird subject to
theorize about but I promise that you're
gonna be surprised by what you find
there for example have you ever wondered
whether or not you could be allergic to
color well I was inspired to ask that
very question from the Netflix series
Wednesday it's actually a much more
interesting and complicated question
than you might initially think so go and
check that video out if you're
interested link is on screen right now
or if you're looking for more
animatronic adjacent horror or coverage
of the Walton files is to the right as
another scary and very dark series
anyway as always my friends thank you
for watching and remember it's all just
a theory a film Theory
and cut